foreign
forged by the tribe in the Kingdom
of London during the early 1800s the
ekakalaka was a Fierce and imposing
weapon designed for executions the
double-edged blade featured a thick
spine and large Crescent tip giving it
the ability to forcibly chop with ease
this powerful weapon with an ornate
shape quickly became associated with
wealth dignity and social position among
men and women in the tribe the
ecaccalaka can be seen in the 2018
Blockbuster film black panther good luck
we'll see you in four days
my name is Nick Hicks what I like most
about blade smithing is the artwork
behind it being able to take something
most folks would look at as a piece of
junk and turn it into something
beautiful and usable I think is the
ultimate artwork I cut the ADC RV at an
angle to establish my scarf weld so that
when I stack those billets up together
I'm going to try and mold those down
into the original blades to make it
Crescent all right slowly but Julie plan
is move a lot of Steel get this thing
shaped hopefully quenched
it's going to be a big heavy Blade the
weapon was made as a serious Chopper it
will be heavy but when you get it in
your hands it will be a commanding tool
I'm going to make sure our quench tank
is going to accept this it's pretty good
the time is definitely an issue here so
I have to get this thing quenched
I think we're pretty good I'm elated
it's straight so I'm feeling great right
now
so I'm going to take the black walnut
I'm going to start working it up we've
got to get this hourglass designed into
it we're going to put our butt cap on
our Bumble cap and then we're going to
weld it and attach it up so that it'll
be strong and tight and ready to go
I want the end of my handle to be
protected as much as I can
I've got everything all together so now
just comes really working on that edge
as much as I can
I feel a tremendous weight lifted off of
my shoulders
my name is Ricardo Villar I'm originally
from Brazil I immigrated to U.S two
years ago in Brazil people know about me
and my knives but in America nobody
knows me if I do well in this
competition people in America probably
gonna know my name too I'm using water
on the Anvil just to make the teeth a
little cooler this is a very old
technique to give me the control to make
the shoulders better
the tip is done time to get into the oil
that's hard I have a blade that's good
to turn in but I think I can do better
so let's turn on the forge and start
over
I love so much this job that I'm making
twice
what took me hours before it just took
me minutes this time
and now I'm done I love when a plane
comes together
I quench the second blade
the blade is straight it's hard and I'm
much more confident in the second
project so the second one is the one I'm
gonna compete with what I did different
in this blade is has a different edge
geometry and a harder tempered
everything is coming together and now
it's time to go and see how does it
gonna perform
for me it's okay I'm happy all right
bladesmens welcome to the kill test
well you're ikakalakas look interesting
and exotic but what kind of lethal
damage can they do well to find that out
I'm going to take your weapon deliver
some lethal blows on this ballistics
dummy Ricardo you're first you ready yes
sir I'm ready let's go for this
all right Ricardo I like your ikakalaka
thank you it's got a good weight to it
the handle construction is comfortable
when you're swinging in this it digs
deep that is a sharp edge and when
you're penetrating it really digs
cuts on the way out overall sir
it will Keel thank you sir
all right Nick your turn sir you ready
I'm ready let's do this
Ricard is a calculate is everything I
expected light fast well-made weapon but
my confidence level is pretty good I'm
fairly confident that my blade will
succeed
the minute you pick up this weapon I
feel the stress on my wrist my elbows
and my shoulder it's so forward heavy
tell me what you feel front shoulder
swing this over and over it's going to
be tough and that's a tendon record
monster and it's not looking good
Nick due to the extreme weight of your
ekakalaka the judges feel that it would
be unsafe to attempt to wield it in the
same manner that they wielded Ricardo's
one-handed blade and because we can't
test it evenly and fairly we cannot move
forward with testing I'd like to invite
you to shake our hands shake your
competitor's hand and then please exit
the forge
it's just totally disappointed
I wanted them to really adjust that
weapon I had a lot of faith in it I knew
it was heavy but one little mistake like
this is something I'm going to learn on
and build and it's going to make me a
better Smith
well Ricardo congratulations you are the
new Fortune fire champion and that is
the title that comes with a check for
ten thousand dollars come on forward
good job I think it's a great weapon
this is great this is amazing
champion
trust what I'm doing and you can twist
on my blades like interest on my work I
I'm really really happy to be the
champion
the nagamaki
reaching its peak use during the Miro
Machi era the nagamaki was a long
two-handed weapon that assisted Samurai
Warriors of feudal Japan for over four
centuries it's slightly curved blade
nearing 30 inches in length in equally
long handle gave the user complete and
precise control making it a highly
effective and lethal slicing weapon
ideal for infantry Warriors combating
Horsemen
traditional Japanese swords have had a
long-standing influence on pop culture
Weaponry especially in fantasy films
like Lord of the Rings where the Elvish
Lang shares a similar Hilton blade
construction as the nagamaki good luck
blade Smiths we'll see you in four days
my name is Bryson Cox I'm 21 years old
I'll describe myself as very shy I like
to work alone when I'm away from my shop
for long periods of time it drives me
crazy the first thing I do is taking it
down to size
[Music]
straightening this blade is a hassle
it's wanting to curve like a banana and
I'm having to straighten it out little
by little
I had to be very meticulous on the
amount of curve it has I feel like I got
a pretty good sound blade but we won't
know anything until after the quench
the blade takes a Warp
oh man that's not good it actually
straightened the blade out that made it
to where I was under parameters for the
minimum Bend in the blade I have to heat
it back up put a bin back in it and
re-quench freaking out a little bit
as I do my second quench I pull my blade
out and it has the bin requirements now
so it worked out oh it's just there
I'm just relieved
it's hard
it's time to start thinking about the
hibaki
for the most part the hibaki is stuck
together it's uglier than sin but this
competition I think mainly is about
function more than pretty the guard is
very important everything needs to be
smooth oh that's a tight fit feels
really good it's just a little bit heavy
the nagamaki being too heavy can make it
unwieldable and make it uncomfortable to
swing around that's right where the
guard is it's a little heavy a mill a
simple pattern into the Super to losing
weight
that actually feels a lot better now
all I like is the wrapping and doing a
final cleanup I only have a few little
things to do on day four
this is cool
[Music]
my name is Jake soul I am 29 years old
my strength when it comes to forging has
to be my ability to adapt which comes
from my military background if you can
make it through military boot camp you
can make it through anything while
ours I lived in Okinawa Japan
Japanese Katana the W-2 that I have is
already pretty close to the parameters
that I need so I really don't have to
draw it out that much
I've got the blade pretty much forged
out it's a little thinner than I wanted
but as long as I get a good heat treat
tomorrow and it's nice and hard it'll
have a little bit of flex to it that's a
straight blade right there
hell yeah I've never wielded anything
that big and I really just can't wait to
test it I can't wait to swing that thing
around in the yard just to have a feel
for how it is
I checked the blade and it's hard it's
straight and I just have such a sense of
relief let's hack it something see if
it's going to break
thank you
just like that it snapped the tip off
about six inches down from the tip I
will not be able to meet parameters with
this blade so I decide to start a new
blade
you know I probably had a stress
fracture the Grain in there is pretty
tight
I got half a day left to hammer out and
Forge out a blade
I was able to forge out a blade grind it
out and get it quenched so I'm just
going to try and meet the parameters and
get the blade turned in and sharp looks
pretty good
have my hibaki done that took me a long
time yesterday I have my Suba pretty
much where I want it
solid that's for sure
once the glue dries on the leather wrap
I go ahead and start this long process
of the Ito wrap
this just so happens to be one of the
hardest builds I've ever done I really
could have used an extra day but I'm
just happy that it's over
oh that is smooth all right lace Miss to
find out how lethal your nagamakis are I
will take your weapons deliver killing
blows slashes and thrusts on this wild
boar carcass
braxony of course you ready for this I'm
ready
all right Braxton your nagamaki here is
definitely not boring it is razor sharp
every cut with this thick wild boar
carcass allowed me to peel off layers of
the very thick high that it has also the
lightness that you have with this blade
allows for switching with the grip here
it's got very good grip in the handle I
can index exactly where the edges at all
times overall sir your nagamaki
will kill thank you all right Jake it's
your turn chop them up
foreign
all right Jake let's talk about your
nagamaki here it's sharp wielding this
weapon is a lot of fun also the weight
you have here and the balance Works
overall sir you're nagamaki we'll kill
thank you next up is the strength test
Dave
now to test the strength and overall
construction of your blades I'll be
chopping into this bamboo now this test
is not about what your blades do to the
bamboo what the bamboo does to your
blades Braxton you're up first you ready
I'm ready
thank you
[Music]
all right Braxton as far as what the
bamboo did to your blade it did nothing
there's no deflection rolls chips
anything on display that's it's as sharp
as one I picked it up nicely done it's a
very strong blade thank you so much all
right Jake you ready
let's do it
all right so your Edge just as sharp as
when it started there are no chips rolls
deformation you slice right through the
bamboo
your handle is a little wide this way
for me
the fact that it's lean this way and
that that wraps so nice and comfortable
is uh it evens it out well done thank
you
all right blade Smiths we know your
blades can kill we know they're strong
now it's time to find out how sharp they
are now unlike the strength test this is
all about what your Edge will do to
these different materials from the
tatami the melons or the sandbags
Braxton you're first you ready for this
I'm ready
[Music]
foreign
Braxton your Edge had no issues at all
cutting through the tatami mats cuts the
melon easily and on sandbags it will cut
through overall sir your weapon it will
cut thank you
Jake your turn you ready do it
all right Jake let's talk about your
nagamaki right here razor sharp it cuts
easily on the tatami cuts the melons and
just off the orders of the corners it
cut it easily overall sir it will cut
thank you this is going to be very hard
for us
blade Smith's the judges have made the
final decision
the new forged and fire Champion is
Braxton congratulations you're the forge
to fire Champion Jake unfortunately your
blade didn't make the cut Ben Abbott's
going to tell you why well Jake you
should be proud you made a beautiful and
effective weapon and for us this came
down to the finest of points the fact
that your blade wasn't quite as finished
and we had a slight preference for
brackman's handle and that's the reason
we're sending you home Jake please
surrender your blade
I think the time frame that I had to
build my second blade definitely had a
factor in it I may not be the forge and
fire Champion but I feel like I
accomplished a lot and earned a
privilege to be here
Braxton congratulations you're the
forest and fire champion and that's the
title that comes with a check for 10
grand good job
I feel great about what I've
accomplished
I'm still shaking it was an awesome
experience and I proved that I can hang
with big guys
the darp Street ganchai
foreign
double-handed sword used in Thailand
during the 18th century featuring a long
single edge slightly curved blade with a
flame-backed spine the weapon was
designed to inflict devastating blows
and slashes on enemies measuring at
nearly five feet long this blade was so
large and intimidating it was used by
guards in the northern kingdom of Lana
now Northern Thailand to scare off
potential Intruders this frightening
weapon can be seen in the 2007 movie
Kingdom of War part 2. good luck
gentlemen we'll see you in four days
good luck
my name is Paul Pinto I'm 19 years old
and I'm from Fairfield Connecticut I
started my YouTube channel about a year
and a half ago one video that went viral
I actually used a tiny Anvil and a tiny
Hammer to forge a miniature ax I don't
know is that like interesting Paul
you're already my favorite for this
challenge I'm going
to there's no grease or oil on them
because that could affect the forage
weld after I get the steel cleaned up I
stack all the pieces up together and do
my initial weld
the next step is to grind in notches all
along the entire thing on both sides and
what that's going to do is expose the
layers of the Damascus they're these
decorative elements of the back of the
sword that stick up and the valley
actually dips down and when caught in
some notches along the spine of the
blade with an angle grinder and that's
going to allow me to use a chisel to pop
those notches up to create the flames
all right
it's time for the heat treat
I'm just really scared because I have no
idea what's going to happen with a blade
this big here we go
pretty good
so happy you have no idea
it's about time to start etching the
blade this is the most magical moment of
making Damascus because you get to
finally see what the pattern is going to
look like still getting streaks though
I don't get it
it's just not at all what I wanted to
see there's a bunch of decarb all over
the entire blade which means I didn't
grind deep enough and the edge is not
going to come out right unless I remove
all of that decarb
I really don't want to grind anymore
because the blade is already as thin as
I'd like it to be I knew in order to
save the pattern I really had to just go
back to the grinder
and I think it's pretty good
this is the Damascus I wanted to see I'm
still kind of concerned that the blade
is a little on the thinner side but
there's nothing I can do now
my name is James Davis I'm 33 years old
I'm from made in North Carolina and I'm
a full-time blacksmith I think I'm most
intimidated by David Baker so for him to
say you've done a great job that's a
huge goal for me right now I'm going to
be using ADC rv2 it's a very good steel
for impact and Edge retention and I
believe the test they're going to be
putting this blade through is going to
need a little bit of both we're going to
do this heat treat this morning
thank you
I didn't feel any pings or pops I'm
happy
I'm going to start working on the handle
I don't have long enough drill bits to
drill all the way into that handle so
I'm going to have to carve out a channel
for that Tang to sit in and make sure
the wood Mary's back together nicely
yeah baby
I made it a little of My Own by adding
some fur from the land around my house I
think that's going to add a little
special touch it is a little on the
heavy side but it's balanced perfectly
it's very wieldable I'd say yeah all I
can tell you is grab it by the rabbit
welcome to the kill test we are darp
Street gun Shy's look intimidating but
are they deadly to find that out I will
take your weapon deliver some killing
blows in this ballistics dummy
James you're up first you ready for this
there's nothing I can do to stop it all
right let's do it
all right James first stop that's a
beast it's very forward heavy so it
definitely feels like a chopper all the
way through now your handle here by
adding this fur around it I can't get a
good grip on it because it's so soft now
your Edge
is sharp well we're all sir
you'll kill thank you all right Paul
your turns are you ready I'm ready let's
do this
[Music]
all right Paul first up I really
appreciated Damascus pattern that you
brought out here now
the fact that I can hold the weapon out
extended like this shows just how light
this weapon is for its size and because
of that I can cut deeply into this
without using the weight just velocity
alone but after that striking skull it's
picked up a little bit of a Bend overall
sir it will heal thank you
all right gentlemen to test the strength
and overall construction of your blades
I'll be chopping into these pots
now remember this is not about what your
blades do to the targets but what the
targets can do to your blades
James here first you ready let it happen
okay
this is a shoulder ripping monster
once you start this thing moving
stopping it is really rough on the
shoulders the fur around the middle here
it's a neat look but it's very slick
actually and then your Edge
is still sharp you know good job thank
you all right Paul you're up you ready
yep okay
good job dude thanks
all right Paul right off this weapon has
a feel that is excellent I can literally
use it with one hand The Edge is still
sharp nice and done thank you
[Music]
all right blade Smith to see how sharp
your weapons are will try to cut through
these pineapples
James here first you ready for this
let's go let's do this
all right James
just a little off the top your Edge is
Sharp Cuts cleaning all the way through
these pineapples it will come thank you
all right follow your turn ready yep
[Music]
there you go man gosh
all right Paul it is research sharp just
the thinness of your metal here cuts
through no resistance if you get the
pineapple heads they're all still
standing right there it's very sharp and
more importantly
thank you
James Paul you've both done an
incredible amount of work however there
can only be one forged and fire champion
in this competition and that champion is
Paul congratulations you're the new
Forge of fire Champion James your blade
just didn't make the cut and David Baker
is going to tell you why James we had a
long discussion about this and what it
comes down to is that rabbit firm at a
very slippery grip all that weight in
that blade made it hard to stop once you
started swinging it that's why we're
letting you go
James please surrender your gun chai
It's been a really great experience I
did the best I could no matter what you
do in life there's gonna be challenges
and you're not going to always succeed
just get back up get back on the horse
Paul congratulations you're the fortune
fire champion and that is a title that
comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars good job brother
[Applause]
I just couldn't be happier this is like
gotta be the craziest thing that's ever
happened to me so far I mean I know I'm
only 19 but I still can't believe it I'm
the forage and fire champion and it
feels incredible
oh
the Japanese great sword
the Japanese Greatsword Rose in
popularity during the 14th century
reaching lengths of up to five feet long
this massive single edge slightly curved
blade was designed to deliver deep
penetrating Cuts upon enemy soldiers on
foot or on Horseback alike
while this enormous weapon became too
impractical for battle by the 17th
century it can still be seen in many
action films including the classic 1954
Carousel movie Seven Samurai
good luck gentlemen we will see you in
four days
my name is Austin Frakes I'm 37 years
old from
a little town right outside of Houston
Texas I'm a sergeant with the local
police department over my professional
career I've seen a lot of the ugly side
of life and a few years ago I picked up
bladesmithing after watching forged and
fire I like to make beautiful knives
this thing is absolutely ridiculous it's
huge it's obscene almost a foot to go in
like hoping I can get it to Links
quickly and get this thing quenched as
quick as possible it's right in between
the two parameters perfect
almost like I played
the Heat Treating process is going to be
difficult due to the extreme length and
the fact that I've only got an 18 inch
long Forge
we are skating I know the blade is good
and hard happy dance
all right that's enough of that
I am putting on faux not real alligator
skin to give this sword a little bit of
my Texas Heritage down here on the dirty
Third Coast everything looks good so far
now it's just time for the handle wrap
just trying to make it so that it's not
uncomfortable for the judge's hands my
hands are now cramping severely as I'm
doing this nearly 21 inches of braid as
I finish it up I think it looks pretty
cool
it just needs an edge and then it's test
time I did grind the blades in and I'm
hoping that the lighter weight and the
thinner profile will help it cut better
while still being thick enough to retain
its Edge during the damage test
whoa
my name is Ian ziermann I'm 19 years old
and I'm from a small rural town of
Bedford Pennsylvania
probably what got me started making
blades was just my dad being a carpenter
we made a lot of wooden blades and I
looked at him and I said wouldn't it be
cool with this with metal and he's like
let's do it all right so we are pretty
much at length to where I want to be I'm
pretty much done and I'm ready to get it
up to temperature and quench it so my
gas forge isn't actually big enough to
do the Heat Treating so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to dig a ditch and
make a kind of like a redneck coal Forge
I have the blade in there I'm just
watching the temperature and just making
sure I don't overheat it things are
definitely heating up literally
this hardened I am really happy with how
it came out sweet
so next thing I need to do is I need to
shape this handle and get it actually
ergonomic and feeling good in your hands
because this handle is pretty big all
right it's starting to fit my hands
really good I really like it it is now a
fully functional sword this thing is a
beast so I got the cashier put on uh
it's shaped I really like it I am ready
for um yeah making it look cool I start
wrapping this handle it's going really
nicely a brown and black contrast is
awesome it's starting to look like a
finished product
there we go very nice fit
cool
places welcome to the dynamic heel test
that's what great disappointment that I
have to say that I will not be able to
wield your weapons to test it but Dave
Baker will be enjoying and doing your
tests
Ian you're first you ready for this go
for it
foreign
so Ian right off scale wise perfect for
my hand the wrap is really well dialed
in your blade every single one of those
cuts it was deadly your Edge is still a
razor blade it lost no Edge whatsoever
nicely done thank you all right awesome
you ready yes sir
oh
[Music]
foreign
Austin right off your sword has a lot of
height to it it's got a lot of Mass to
it but it's really nicely balanced which
I like an issue there are some dull
spots on your blade dull enough that I
can run my finger back and forth on it
but I really like the look of this blade
I'm actually done thank you
all right blade Smiths welcome to my
Dynamic test they steal wind chime and
fish slice
Ian you're up first you ready for this
not really
well get ready it's coming
[Music]
foreign
first things first I'm impressed this
Edge doesn't really show much of any
indication that had been smashed into
steel wind chimes you know you could see
the cuts on all these fish are nice and
clean the handle wrap is really
comfortable the dimensions are good all
in all nice job thank you
all right Austin you're up man how you
feeling let's get it over with all right
pew
[Music]
all right Austin well you're all in one
piece well done where I was hitting the
wind chimes each time I hit them you
lost more and more of your Edge there's
some rolls I get a fingernail underneath
so as I was progressing through the fish
they became more and more difficult to
cut through but all in all I think he
did a great job thank you
foreign
you both impressed us the entire
competition but at the end of it only
one of you can come out on top earn the
title of Fortune fire champion and a
check for ten thousand dollars today's
Fortune fire Champion is
Ian very well done Austin unfortunately
your blade did not make the cut and
Doug's gonna tell you why
Austin what it came down to is the
darling you took during our test it just
underperformed on the dynamic kill and
sharpness test and those are the reasons
why I didn't win today I agree
completely
so Austin it's been an absolute pleasure
watching you pound steel in the Forge
and come out with two massive blades but
unfortunately your time this competition
has ended once I think of coming out but
I'm about to ask you to please step off
the fourth floor thanks y'all I don't
like to lose but Ian's great guy to lose
two that definitely makes it easier
well Ian congratulations man that makes
you a fortune fire Champion you'll be
getting a check for ten thousand dollars
very well done
I'm still kind of in shock still a
little shaky but really excited I'm
really thankful how you feeling Bud
pretty good thank you thank you guys not
people that I've met be knowing what I
can do in such a short amount of time
it's just I learned so much
foreign
[Music]
dating back to the Middle Ages the
Crusader sword was the European Knight's
weapon of choice as they conquered the
Holy Land This single-handed
medium-length long sword also contained
a double edge that tapered at the end
making it the ideal weapon for piercing
the emerging plate armor that was found
on most battlefields the most famous
Crusader sword was the legendary
Excalibur wielded by King Arthur
Crusader sword was also carried by the
Knights Templar who were highlighted in
films like kingdom of heaven and Indiana
Jones in the Last Crusade
good luck we will see you in five days
my name is Peter Burt the first sword
that I made I gave to my high school
girlfriend she was not very excited
about it my strategy here is to make a
Damascus Billet which is a laminated bar
made up of multiple layers of Steel and
a jelly roll is a specific pattern in
Damascus where you actually roll the
steel up on itself kind of like a
cinnamon bun
pretty tight
the jelly roll has reached the point
that I need to get it into the hammer to
squeeze it down on itself
proceed to forging this out
I got plenty of wet that's nice and toy
I feel great about what I've made and if
Dave beats it that means he's brought
something incredible
I'm Dave roederer when I was 16. I
followed the sound of an anvil and I met
a man that was forging a knife got to
watch it being done and I've been making
knives ever since
I want to make sure that this is going
to perform without fail
everything's good there so I'm gonna put
the blade in oh well I'm going to pull
it out it's enough for it to flash
anytime that thing got hot in the Forge
it would work I could literally watch it
then
this is called a three pin
straightening method I'm going to either
straighten this blade or I'm going to
snap it
I really don't like doing this
so luckily the blade didn't break in the
Vise I was able to fix the warp now I
got to get the sword finished the handle
is Walnut
put inside the handle a riser underneath
the leather it's pleading to the eye and
it helps with the grip
confidence level is pretty high I'm
really pleased with the outcome of this
I've got a great chance at this in the
end with the judges
while the Crusader sword was quite
powerful and effective on foot and sword
sword combat there is a method of
delivery that made it even more
destructive
from horseback
[Music]
that Rider is going to use your weapons
to attack that ballistics gel torso
that's wearing a great Helm gorget and
tunic
okay I suggest we get out of the way I'm
very nervous full Gallop on Horseback
that's a lot of power to put into a
sword Dave you're up first are you ready
I ain't gonna get anywhere here three
two one engage
[Music]
nice hit that is absolutely awesome Pete
your sword's up next let's see some
blood
I feel great that my sword held up well
but it didn't cut through the cloth
armor to assess the damage and perform
the kill test I'm gonna hand you over to
Doug
okay Dave
it's got some weight to it
see if your sword should feel a bit
heavy in the hand
slashing feels good
let's see if it'll cut
okay
oh
you can see it points like a spear
beautiful thrusting capability
it's a killer Pete
so I'm now testing for the thrusting
with length
it's got a lot of weight to it
let's see what's going to do on a kill
test let's see
[Music]
it will kill
all right gentlemen that concludes the
kill test now we're gonna head back to
the forge where we are going to perform
the strength test
gentlemen a sword in combat went through
extreme stresses so to test this I'm
going to take five blows against these
femurs see how far through we can get
with each of your weapons
okay
Pete you ready I'm ready all right
and while I was chopping this this ring
up here pretty rough on the hand okay
happy that my sword is still in one
piece at the end of this
got about halfway through that bone
blowing pieces off of it
and still has an edge okay
nice job thank you
Dave you're up next you ready
sure
bent
oh
a lot of stress in that blade
kidding you can see the edge folded over
yeah
sort of bent right around that point of
impact right there
you can see we chopped right through
this bone about three blows to crack
that open
well done
you've both been outstanding competitors
through three rounds of competition
but
there can only be one
forged and fire champion
Jay
oh Pete that Damascus blade was
beautiful I mean getting all those welds
folded together grinding that all evenly
heat treating it the way you did it
stood up to all the tests you did a
wonderful job on that piece of Steel
I had a couple of issues with the way
your handle was put together with that
spacer the spacer really started chewing
into my hand they just couldn't get a
good grip up around the top of the sword
that's an issue comments for Dave well
Dave even though their overall look of
your sword and the design of your handle
was very appealing obviously it was a
heat treatment issue during the tests
your blade folded over and that really
bit you in the testing
Dave I love the design of your blade
very clean lines your handle felt very
good in the hand it's sharp it thrust
well but in the end it failed when we
started slicing the bones Pete
you aren't the forged Empire Champion
congratulations
Dave your sword felt great in the hand
but when I used it on those bones boy it
just bent right over the top and a heat
treat issue like that we just can't let
that through
Dave did an outstanding job
please surrender your weapon
the judge's decision was what it was and
if I can't change it then why worry
about it Pete congratulations you're
receiving a check for ten thousand
dollars that's pretty nice how do you
feel I feel great I feel really good I
think my wife we get to Hawaii we're
gonna lie back and relax she's had to
put up with me being gone for this
she deserves it
[Music]